[Musique]
es-tu sûr que c'est ici nous avons appelé Gotham
[ __ ] il n'a pas été vu depuis plus d'un an
qu'est-ce qui a
disparu ils ont dit qu'ils pensaient qu'il
pourrait être mort pourquoi venir ici pourquoi Detroit
le temps où est Batman
hé petits oiseaux seuls
espérons juste  l'hélicoptère qui
passe je suis le détective Dick Grayson nous
voulons parler de ce qui s'est passé pouvez-vous
m'aider Rachel c'est comme ça qu'elle appelle
il y a quelque chose en moi rien de
mal ne va arriver tu ne t'inquiètes pas prendre
soin d'un enfant c'est compliqué tu sais
que  mieux que quiconque
je sais à quel point ça doit être guéri de faire ce que
Bruce a fait pour toi et tu as perdu tes
parents ce qui s'est passé entre toi et
Bruce suppose que nous avions des idées différentes sur la
façon de faire le travail nous allons aller voir de
vieux amis
tada m'appeler  qu'est-ce que tu veux de moi
je te cherchais il y a des
gens là-bas qui essaient de te faire du mal
je sens un danger
là-bas tu es cher
que fais-tu nous devons tous faire des
sacrifices enfant
tu
t'es laissé derrière
toi [Musique]